Ще три тижні тому біля цього популярного кафе в центрі Кельна
було не проштовхнутися. Хтось сидів усередині і працював,
а хтось пив каву на вулиці з друзями. Сьогодні все по-іншому.
Однак власники вирішили не закривати кафе через епідемію коронавірусу
і використовують дозволені методи роботи.
Ми обрали концепцію "кава з собою". Раніше ми теж пропонували такий варіант,
але він не користувався особливим попитом.
Нині ж гості не можуть прийти до нас і посидіти, тож концепція "to go" працює зараз добре.
Також ми продаємо багато сертифікатів, філіжанки з нашим логотипом, зерна у вакуумі,
щоб люди могли варити каву вдома. Коли світить сонце, багато перехожих до нас заходять.
І все ж потік клієнтів скоротився на 50 відсотків.
Нині кафе продає близько 100-150 горняток з логотипом щодня.
На запитання, чи не небезпечно приходити сюди,
нас запевнили, що безпека для співробітників - на першому місці:
постійно всі поверхні дезінфікуються, в кафе можна заходити лише по одному,
оплата - безконтактним способом.
Раніше штат кафе був 8 співробітників. Нині ж працюють 4 людини.
Держава обіцяє малим підприємствам до п'яти осіб одноразову допомогу:
9 тисяч євро на три місяці.
У кафе не впевнені, що це сильно допоможе.
Ми дуже сподіваємося, що обмежувальні заходи якомога швидше скасують.
Сподіваємося на велику підтримку з боку держави.
На фінансову підтримку або на полегшення податкового тягаря, щоб знизили ПДВ,
щоб ми могли забезпечити своє існування.
Рафет Айдогду - власник двох інших популярних кельнських кафе,
де можна було не тільки випити капучино або латте, а й смачно поїсти.
Він вирішив свої заклади взагалі закрити.
На його думку, концепція "to go" не здатна покрити всі витрати.
Економічно, на наш погляд, така модель не має сенсу,
адже йдеться і про зарплати співробітникам, і про використання обладнання.
Ми зрозуміли, що працювати не зможемо, тому й закрилися.
Тим більше, що дуже мало людей зараз виходять на вулицю. Більшість сидить удома.
Заклади Рафета, як i інші невеликі кафе і ресторани Німеччини,
беруть участь в акції "підтримай місцевий бізнес".
Рафет, зокрема, робить ставку на торгівлю кавовими зернами онлайн,
краудфандінг та на сертифікати, які можна буде потім обміняти.
І все ж багатьом у Німеччині очевидно, що значна частина кафе і ресторанів,
якщо епідемія затягнеться, ймовірно, не зможуть відкритися знову,
адже обмежувальні заходи, запроваджені для боротьби з коронавірусом,
можуть призвести до серйозних економічних наслідків.
Про повну невизначеність говорять і в цій кондитерській.
Раніше, приміром, у суботу на зміну виходили до 8-10 співробітників. Нині ж працює лише одна.
Наш оборот скоротився на 80 відсотків.
В одному з наших кафе, яке знаходиться в житловому районі і де мешкає багато людей,
це число становить 20 відсотків. А от у центрі,
куди люди приїздили зазвичай за покупками,
частота відвідувань зійшла майже нанівець,
оборот знизився на 90 відсотків.
Маттіас Людвіґс, у минулому кондитер року
за версією одного відомого ресторанного путівника,
каже, що якщо справи підуть ще гірше, то, мабуть,
доведеться зрештою закрити заклади і почати
продавати тістечка з віконця кухні або розвозити їх на машині.
Нам доводиться виробляти значно менше.
У кондитерському цеху зараз працюють лише дві особи замість 6-7.
Ми пропонуємо доставку по Кельну (за суму замовлення) від 25 євро.
Така опція сподобалася нашим клієнтам.
Сьогодні я сам дві години роз'їжджав містом. 10 замовлень.
Ок, 10 замовлень - це краще, ніж нічого. Для нас це навіть плюс.
Завантажив у машину, там прохолодно.
Від чого повністю відмовився Маттіас, то це від кондитерських курсів,
які він проводив у цьому цеху щотижня. Тепер щоп'ятниці
він готує і ділиться досвідом за допомогою відеоконференцій.
Однак прямого контакту з учнями все одно дуже бракує.